joining us now another brilliant
beautiful and talented woman she's a
mama of three with her husband stephen
curry
and she has a new cookbook out right now
it's called the full plate
you should buy it if you like food let's
dial in aisha curry
[Music]
you get this all the time but just take
the compliment you
are perhaps one of the most beautiful
women i've ever seen on the planet
that's
very sweet stop it i mean even in that
dress
oh my gosh like god damn very good he
had a good day with you ma'am okay
so aisha how is your mommy i know you
have wine yes
so how is your mommy pandemic going is
remote learning the worst for you as
well
it's going right like it's going um
but luckily for me stefan has really
stepped in
um with the education and their
schooling yeah and i'm okay with that
because i said you know i birthed
them so now you can birth and nurture
their education
i get it so and he's actually doing it
he's doing it yeah i'm so grateful but
it's you know
he's making up for lost time to be quite
frank because he
would sleep through all of the diaper
changes in the late nights when they
were babies and so now this is his
strong suit
well it's all about being a good team so
that's awesome um well you have an
awesome new cookbook called the full
plate and
what can we expect to find in it it
looks delicious what you're eating oh my
god yes
i'm so excited about this cookbook and
it'll be four years almost to the day
since the first book came out
and with this book you know life was
really chaotic and i wanted the book to
reflect that
and so it's filled with quick easy
recipes that don't lack flavor because
i've always found that a lot of them
that are quick
lack that umami and that deliciousness
so there's 15
20 30 minute recipes nothing ever over
an hour
and i think the best part about the book
is there's a huge cocktails chapter
and i highly encourage people to make a
cocktail first
so that they can drink while making the
meal yeah that's the only time you'll
find me cooking is if there is a glass
of wine involved
um it has to be do your kids like
cooking have you have you gotten them
into it
they do they love helping me um as much
as i let them
um so we we often cook together
um and i've lucked out with them because
they're super adventurous eaters
um so that's always been nice but i
think it's because they cook with me
and have a hand in making the meals
occasionally um that's why they're
interested in trying new things
yeah my daughter's always every time
we're in the kitchen together she always
wants to use the knife and i'm like it's
a little weird how much you want to use
the knife
it's actually a little um so are your
kids into cooking don't they like it
more into it if i was more into it
look we have strengths and weaknesses
and mine is not in the kitchen i'm going
to buy it
not either i'm going to buy the book buy
the book mine aren't into cooking or
eating actually
to see that you're so beautiful and you
have adventurous eaters as children
that's
ruined oh my god my boy doesn't eat
really at all but my
girl will she's like i'll eat anything
as long as there's some kind of treat
coming she's like i will eat anything
in the world yeah she's kind of like
that so what you you also launched a
magazine sweet july
um so what i know that's amazing like
who launches
magazines like what was your inspiration
for that i don't know i'm still trying
to figure out like how they
they chose me to do this but i'm
i'm so thrilled about it i you know it's
called sweet july because all of the
kids were born in july and it's one of
the happiest times in our life
and one of the most exciting and i was
like why can't
we implement the way that we feel today
into our everyday life
so the magazine's really a mantra to
just you know keep it positive keep it
fresh and exciting
every single day and there are little
ways that you can do that
along the way so it's celebrating the
small moments along with the big things
and so that's how sweet july came about
and it's just this
reflection of diversity and inclusivity
and i'm just
excited about it the second issue comes
out next month
and i can't wait oh my god that's
incredible i feel like you're doing
so many things um so aisha's book y'all
is called the full plate and it's
available now and i literally want
whatever you're eating on the cover of
it it looks
amazing um and look at that is that what
it is
yes it is so good oh my god i would eat
that
well i would if you made it i'm it looks
like you're awesome so i would eat
anything you made but um
and everybody look out for sweet july at
your local newsstand i love how you came
up with the name of your magazine as
well that is so beautiful